you hear everything they're saying back
there don't like any of it is he always
like this
yo would wind up are you on crack or
what is it these are mainly when I get
it here kids high school kids the
average person that works right here I'm
not sure they're dumb it can't ask no
people to do smart things I'm gonna I'm
a kid I'm harsh I'm over the top fear
equals respect you're gonna have to rule
with an iron fist man
a style that he's using to intimidate he
believes truly that's a great method for
controlling this town I don't agree with
that
fear equals many things that you don't
want in a work environment don't stop my
tell I see somebody take my towel I'm
gonna kick you strength
little baby nuts you gotta pull your
skirt up there good work back here if
they do is consequences here where it
hurts their pocket it's upsetting to me
I'm pinching on the inside when I hear
West speak I'm up throw a classic
definition of a bully this is
unacceptable
I can't take it anymore and I will not
allow it here see you shortly
he's real soft